[Music]
you
perfect for fun teasing work was here do
with this one
hard-working strong se - I told you to
keep your place Congo as I was saying
these one is strong as an ox it's in
good health and all not guarding the
missing dolls mama don't be afraid that
I'm a friend who did this your master
know this son oh please that be strong
I'll get you to safety
you'll pay for this God hurry we've got
rats in the barn
I will in my daughter wandering alone at
dawn where have you been
after the nightmare I want to take care
dear stepmother I'm grown now you
needn't worry for my safety you
underestimate the dangers of the world
if not your safety under your reputation
why must you be so ad strong I wish you
would in truth melon I'm in need of your
assistance
I'm afraid it's urgent what now while
walking I was started by crisis distress
following them I discovered a woman a
slave badly wounded where is she
I will send up she awaits in a wagon
outside in the street Evelyn don't be
cross I knew you'd know the thing to do
I couldn't risk leaving her to perish or
worse worse you have already sentenced
her to persecution by your very
impulsive Nasseri well I will not turn
my back now not that you have left me
much choice
I will see that she is treated in utmost
discretion
ah Thank You Madeline in the meantime
hurry to town and fetch our new
traveling clothes go quickly we have no
time to lose would you be so kind as to
tell me what happened with mr. the same
axle shipment hey why would you want to
know but don't you worry my little army
the cargo found its way to the intended
recipient let me pour you a cup I dare
you to tell me this isn't the best
Madeira wine that ever graced your
heavenly lips if if you insist Capitan I
do you will not find a better Vantage in
all of the new world I'm intrigued truly
where does your lettuce suspect spread
is the only thing I am I am Carlos going
yes we meet again the way all three of
Jo look familiar but sure are welcome
back to my coming
I've manhood for I don't think or we can
concern right here what do you know
about Rafael Joaquin de Ferran I'm
afraid is not invited
what's your business with him he pays
for transport to and from New Orleans a
soul I do transport the things and get
paid he's paid transport paid back and
forth the farther back what is he doing
why New Orleans I do not know Senor de
faire is a very secretive man No thank
you for your time Capitan
you
[Music]